honestly the best thing about this is
that I get to eat chocolate souffle
every day the worst thing about this is
that I've eaten chocolate souffle every
day
[Music]
hi I'm Alex clearly I've been making a
lot of giant things lately and I decided
why not make my all-time favorite
dessert giant and that is a chocolate
souffle if only my favorite dessert was
something a little bit easier people
always say what came first the chicken
or the egg in this case it's the egg
with any souffle the main ingredient is
the egg you have to separate your eggs
into yolks and whites I like to crack my
eggs on the surface of the table as
opposed to like the bowl because you'll
get less like shortage obviously this is
giant so I'm gonna be using a lot of
eggs I'm gonna use this whole carton so
I need 12 egg whites and then 6 egg
yolks it's so much easier to use your
hands to separate your yolks so you just
want to be really careful not to get any
yolk in your whites because it will
affect the way your egg whites whip up I
want 16 ounces of semi-sweet chocolate
and each bar is 2 ounces therefore I
need 8 I'm gonna chop up my chocolate it
doesn't have to be pretty because we're
gonna melt it all down but you don't
want to just smell down full bars of
chocolate that would have been bad so
before I even start I need to preheat
and prepare my oven the first time I've
ever remembered to preheat my oven but
it's important because if it's not ready
to go once you finish making your
souffles they made the flame and that's
the biggest risk you run with making a
souffle so I'm gonna be using a little
bit of a makeshift double boiler I just
have a little bit of water going
idiom heat and this will just heat up
the chocolate and much more gently than
a direct heat will and with that I'm
adding four tablespoons of
unsalted butter honestly we could stop
here and it would be delicious butter
and chocolate my butter has melted down
so I'm just gonna take this off the heat
careful because it is hot I'm gonna add
a half a teaspoon of salt and two
teaspoons of vanilla before we move on
to the next step we are going to prep
our giant souffle dish coating your dish
with this butter and sugar will help
your souffle not stick to the edges and
also it supposedly allows it to rise
from the dish which is a very important
part of this I'm going to whip up my egg
yolks with 1/4 of a cup of sugar I wish
I used a hand mixer I'm going to add
this to our chocolate when you're
folding you want to scrape the bottom of
the bowl and bring it to the top just to
make sure we get kind of an even fold an
even mix so now I'm just gonna set this
aside it can hang out while we move on
to our which by the way I am definitely
going to be using a hand mixer so of
course a classic souffle is really airy
and light and kind of loud like so it's
really important to get them to stiff
peaks and incorporate lots of air into
it if not your souffles won't rise so
now that my egg whites have turned
opaque and are leaving new trails I'm
gonna start gradually adding 1/2 a cup
of sugar look how beautiful that is
yep so we're bringing back our place and
now we're gonna mix the two together I'm
gonna start by lightening the base this
means putting about a half a cup of our
egg whites into the chocolate mixture
when you lighten the base it just makes
it easier to add the rest of the egg
whites without deflating it too much
again with this arm workout to forget
the gym just make a souffle I have my
prepared dish and I'm just going to get
this batter in here whoo it looks really
nice and airy so that's good I'm gonna
use a offset spatula to even out this
and lastly I'm going to run my thumb
around the edge to create kind of like a
little order around the souffle and this
will also help it to rise nicely into
the oven she goes this is always the
most nerve-wracking part to opening the
oven
whoa okay well it's risen I'm just gonna
call our head of culinary Claire King
and see what she thinks
hi Claire so it is a souffle it has a
crock I don't know if that's like okay I
[Music]
don't do any flour this is our first one
okay stay - I'm feeling pretty confident
because yesterday our tests went really
well
considering the large crack in the top
of the souffle now I have a couple of
theories as to why that happened one
theory is that I overfilled the dish and
the other theory is that there's too
much moisture in my batter and not
enough stability the first theory is
easier to remedy so I'm going to try to
do that first
I made a double recipe yesterday and I
still have batter left over so I'm
actually just going to do a single
souffle recipe I'm feeling good today
because really our only faults yesterday
was the crack in the top haha fault
that's a dumb joke I'm a little worried
because it is pretty low I don't know
it's like I should be hitting a little
higher than this but you don't know
until you try right all right so it's
not perfect
I definitely underfilled the dish this
time still have a pretty big crack in
the top of my souffle I'm gonna try
baking it next time with a water bath
because it will gradually raise the heat
rather than like shucking it in
and that might be causing the san
andreas fault okay I've made the same
exact batter for the third time
hopefully third time is a charm I also
did one and a half batches because the
first time we made too much the second
time we made too little
hopefully the third time we meet
somewhere in the middle so now I'm going
to make my water boss you can just take
a pan with a little bit deeper and
before we put it in the oven we're gonna
fill it not quite halfway up with some
hot water now I'm going to stick this in
the oven very carefully don't be fooled
by we have way less crackage which is
good but not enough lift
unfortunately third time was not the
charm all right so I did a little bit of
thinking water bath it's definitely not
the right way to go for this for a
souffle it's really important to get
that intense heat in order for your
souffle to actually rise so that's why
our souffle fell flat today I'm going up
my method a little bit I'm going to be
making a chocolate pastry cream and use
that for my face I'm gonna start by
scalding my milk I don't want to bring
this to a boil so I'm gonna watch it
I'll actually watch it this time you
don't want to burn your table so have a
little towel down now I'm gonna add in
12 ounces of my chocolate okay so we've
got our chocolate milk before I add the
chocolate I'm gonna mix together these
egg yolks some sugar some flour a little
bit of vanilla so I'm gonna add just a
half a cup of our hot chocolate milk
mixture into our egg yolks you don't
want to just mix it all together right
off the bat because we have eggs in here
and they will cook so tempering is just
a way kind of
slowly bring up the heat and make sure
everything mixes thoroughly we're gonna
heat this all up it's thick so I
transferred my pastry cream to a bowl
I'm gonna cover it with plastic wrap and
I'm gonna press it down to the surface
and now we will put it in the fridge
all right time to whip our egg whites we
are almost at the end I can almost taste
that jaar jaar souffle I know good
tastes well by now
so egg whites cream of tartar this part
is all the same alright time to add my
sugar
luckily I'm naturally very loud yum yum
yum this looks so good from now on
the technique we're doing is exactly the
same so again my dish is completely
prepared and the batter is actually like
perfectly incorporated I'm not seeing
any white streaks or really dark parts
so that's a good sign so I preheated my
oven to 400 degrees right before I put
my souffle in I turned the temperature
down to 375 just so my souffle has that
really intense initial heat in order for
it to rise we're gonna be baking it for
about 40 to 45 minutes oh my gosh wow it
looks so good so one of the really
difficult parts about a souffle is
telling when it's actually done a lot of
people are always so scared about
souffles falling but naturally once you
take your souffle out of the oven it's
going to eventually deflate but again
souffle is a dessert you're gonna want
to serve immediately timing is
everything here people so this is my
favorite dessert
I want to serve it the way I like to eat
it and that's with whipped cream also
another great way to cover up anything
you're trying to hide oh my god is so
good okay let's go for it okay that was
a little messy okay okay finally giant
chocolate souffle done cracked a lot of
eggs cracked a lot of souffles if I
learned anything it's that I fall you
fall
souffles they fall they're delicious and
you should make them and you should eat
them I don't have a spoon I'm gonna take
this home or something
[Music]